[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يمشي ك ك يمشي ك
[تصفيق]
ك مهما كان مهما كان حتى لو كان الادوار
اللي راحت ننساها لكن احنا عندنا امل باذن
الله ان الدور ال 16 الجاي ان يكون المتخب
مغاير باذن الله منينا والله الفوز بس
التعادل يعني يعتبر ان فوزهو متاهل باذن
الله المباريات الجاي يكون يعني بيض الوجه
حلوه بس شوي يعني تحمسنا واجد عشان يعني
يطلع صفر صفر على بالنا بتكون اواد 3 واحد
شي كذا
يعني لا صحيح ما جت اهداف لكن الحمد لله
ان المركز الاول حص وما يرجع ان شاء الله
المنتخب السعودي للسعوديه الا هو حامل كاس
اسيا اليوم فقط استراحه محارب استراحه
محارب والجاي راح يرجع البطل باذن الله
والكاس السعودي اي عجيبه يا ريت ان
السعوديه فازوا الوجيه الجديده هذه تلعب
لان مباراه تحصيل حاصل وع اساس الدور ال
16 جاي دور الثمانيه دور الاربعه مباريات
قويه وجامده وخروج مغلوب فلا بد يشارك
بالبديل على اساس ش
الاساسيه كيف تثبت على مجموعه لا انت ممكن
اللاعب نسق اللاعب اذا جا يلعب نسق
المباراه كامل انا ما قاعد اجرب في مبديه
لكن ان شاء الله نتمنى المامول ان احنا
نتطور من مرحله ال مرحله وكوريا لا تعلم
ما
[تصفيق]
ينتظرها
he
he
[موسيقى]